alors c'est vous qui avez obtenu la
seule interview française de Donald
Trump européenne même [ __ ] la classe
alors Donald Trump pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est les idées de Le
Pen mais dans le corps de François
Valéry voilà à peu près
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire Tom
villa
[Applaudissements]
bon si une façon de te dire que je
renouvelle ton stage
c'est cool
alors beau plateau Thierry ce soir mais
ce soir c'est pas évident parce que
voilà je vous le dis voilà Jeff c'est un
copain donc je vais pas défoncer un
copain André Bercoff voilà
Ornella fleurie c'est une fille je veux
pas défoncer une fille voilà donc
Pascal Obispo bonsoir par contre
[Applaudissements]
un peu de bœuf
chanteur chauve marié un mannequin s'il
avait été noir on aurait réussi dommage
on a Pascal Obispo
Pascal Obispo faut pas l'oublier c'est
les tubes c'est aussi un showman et
d'ailleurs Pascal vous avez déclaré je
me sens inutile si je ne pars pas en
tournée alors je vous rassure parce que
votre tourneurs ils pensent exactement
la même chose
alors votre dernière album s'appelle
billets de femme voilà il a été fait à
partir des poèmes de Marceline
Desbordes-Valmore datant 1819 alors
Pascal vous avez dit que c'est en
trouvant un vieux carnet de votre papa
vous avez découvert cette poétesse moi
je suis sûr que la vraie histoire c'est
Line Renaud aussi d'action qui lui a
donné les poèmes de sa vieille copine de
scène
[Applaudissements]
Jeff panacloc Jeff le garçon qui a
dépoussiéré la ventriloki voilà alors le
principe de la ventriloquille je le
rappelle c'est de parler sans bouger les
lèvres comme Didier Deschamps et
en ce moment parce que faire des vannes
aux invités il a fait pendant trois ans
au plus grand cabaret du monde sans
déconner va faire des blagues ou entre
deux jongleurs bulgares et trois
danseuses portoricaines
en tout cas mine de rien Jeff et
Jean-Marc c'est le seul duo qui n'a
aucune chance de se séparer c'est vrai
si un jour ils sont plus ensemble c'est
juste parce que Jeff faudra oublier sa
valise avec Jean-Marc dedans l'aéroport
en plus votre bureau il a peur de rien
la plus grande peur à la limite c'est
c'est comme Amanda Lear c'est que
Jean-Marc et une couture qui lâche à la
limite mais
pourquoi mais parce qu'elle est jeune
elle est jolie elle est drôle il y a
forcément un truc qui cloche si tu as
tué ta soeur jumelle quand tu étais
petit tu peux nous le dire
alors vous jouez votre spectacle au
Point Virgule spectacle des conseillers
au moins de 16 ans c'est con c'est con
non mais si parce que ça coupe une
partie du public quoi les pédophiles
aussi ils ont droit de se marrer
Bercoff alors actuellement vous êtes
journaliste à Valeurs Actuelles alors
journal un petit peu de droite on peut
le dire voilà bien à droite c'est entre
minutes et Picsou Magazine voilà alors
c'est vous qui avez obtenu la seule
interview française de Donald Trump
européenne même [ __ ] la classe alors
Donald Trump pour ceux qui connaissent
pas c'est les idées de Le Pen mais dans
le corps de François Valéry voilà à peu
près
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con tirer
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser
tout ça pour ça exactement Pascal Obispo
Pascal votre votre fils s'appelle Sean
sa sœur s'appelle seven le prochain il
va s'appeler comment Ocean's Eleven ou
bien
on est la fleurie on est là vous êtes en
couple avec l'humoriste Mustapha et la
Tracy qui a produit et co-écrit votre
spectacle comment ça se passe quand vous
disputez il vous met une sale critique
sur Billetreduc
ça arrive ouais André Bercoff André vous
qui avez passé plus d'une heure avec
Donald Trump qu'est-ce qui a été le plus
dur à supporter c'est propos racistes ou
sa coupe de cheveux
ni l'un ni l'autre et pour terminer Jeff
panacloc on vous a vu dans l'émission La
Parenthèse inattendue d'ailleurs vous
avez versé une petite larme c'est si dur
que ça de rester un weekend entier chez
Lopez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu